welcome everybody before we proceed I
would like to thank three people who are
who were very instrumental in arranging
this event Katie
L Lyndsay Weis and Wesley Fox thank you
very much guys for all your help but
mostly thanks to our guests
Vladimir Karim Rosa well let me start
with congratulations Volodya on being
the very first recipient of the Sergei
Magnitsky Human Rights Prize believe in
London couple of weeks ago what was it
like first of all thank you so much for
the invitation it's always an honor and
a pleasure to be here at the American
Enterprise Institute and to the events
with with Leon it's becoming a tradition
now so it was it was indeed on a 16th of
November the day that Sergey Magnitsky
was killed in Montrose Kachina prison
back in in 2009 and they had the annual
Magnitsky Human Rights Awards in London
this is a biannual ceremony and I was
indeed honored and very humbled to
receive one this year I don't certainly
don't think that I'm worthy of any kind
of award but I know I will cherish this
for the rest of my life it's it's a
great honor but more than that I'm very
proud to have played a small part in
this in this process of convincing
members of the US Congress five years
ago now in fact exactly five years ago
in December 2012 this happened to pass a
law which was named in memory and in
honor of Sergey Magnitsky and which
introduced what should really be a
simple and straightforward principle but
was in fact a groundbreaking principle
in international practice it was the
principle that responsibility for human
rights abuse should be assigned to where
it actually belongs not to an entire
country and to all the citizens of that
country as general sanctions do but to
the actual people who perpetrate human
rights abuses and corruption so what the
Magnitsky I did is it laid down the
principle that those people those
Russian officials and those oligarchs in
and around the Putin regime who are
responsible for human rights abuse and
corruption
will no longer be able to receive visas
to the US and use the US financial and
banking system for their personal gain
and the reason this is this is so
important is because of the nature of of
the Putin regime the way it is
structured and the fundamental hypocrisy
and a double standard that is right at
the heart of the Putin regime and then
is that the people who are in charge of
the Russian government today they want
to steal in Russia but spend in the West
and this is the way they have done
things for years the same people who
undermine and violate and abuse the most
basic norms of democratic society at
home want to use the privileges and
opportunities of democratic society
Western countries for themselves and for
their families you know they want to
educate their children in Western
schools they want to keep their money in
Western banks when I say their money
that's the money that actually stolen
from the Russian people they want to buy
high-class real estate in yours and
luxury cars and wherever else in in
Western countries and we think that this
hypocrisy and this double standard has
to stop and this was the premise behind
the Magnitsky Act and I'm and I'm proud
to have played my small part in helping
pass this measure into law and when the
Magnitsky Act was passed exactly five
years ago at the end of 2012 Boris
Nemtsov and I was sitting on that day in
the visitors gather of the US House of
Representatives chamber watching as they
were voting on this on his bill and as
his bill was becoming law in front of
our eyes
and I remember Boris said on that day
that this is the most pro-russian law
ever passed in any foreign country
because it holds to account those who
violate the rights of Russian citizens
and those who steal the money of Russian
taxpayers and I'm happy to say that
since then since the Magnitsky Act was
passed here in the u.s. five years ago
three more countries have followed this
example Canada Estonia and Lithuania
Lithuania just last week the president
of Lithuania Dallaglio bar sky2 signed
this time this bill into law now being
vilius next week to meet with members of
lithuanian parliament and to thank them
for doing this and we hope that other
countries other Western democracies also
take a lead on this issue and send a
message to those crooks and those human
rights abuses in the Putin regime though
they will no longer be welcome in
Western democratic countries and is one
other thing that Boris Nemtsov said back
five years ago when one of Magnitsky law
was being passed here he said that when
Russia becomes a democratic country with
the rule of law he wanted to be the
first one to go back to the US and other
Western countries and advocate for a
repeal of the Magnitsky Act because it
will no longer be needed because we will
have a real justice system and a real
rule of law system that will be able to
take care of the crooks and the abuses
and the corrupt officials now of course
we know that he will not be doing that
and you know the last two years have
taught me to be very careful about
making predictions but I certainly hope
to be able to one day go back here and
to Ottawa and to Vilnius and Tallinn and
hopefully London and other capitals of
democratic countries to say that this
law is no longer needed because we have
a system of government a real system of
government and justice in the rule of
law that is able to protect those
principle well thank you very much
followed yeah you know it's always I
mean they're they're multiple pleasures
in chatting with you in public but one
of them is that is that you're such an
unusual combination of
you know of an oxford-educated Cambrian
bridge sorry like if you said that I'm
from some Petersburg yeah all right
Cambridge educators historian and in an
opposition activist so so let me let me
you know I mean I think I think it's the
same have that just maybe different
halves or different colors but all right
let's let's stress the the analyst part
of your hat looks like Russia is
emerging from from a recession I mean
there are various reasons why primarily
it's not because of investment
it's primarily because people borrow and
spend and and but whatever whatever the
reason the consensus is about 1.7
percent GDP growth at the same time
paradoxically this is the fourth year in
a row where the real income us are
falling and Alexei Kudrin to whom we
will return probably known to everybody
I don't need to introduce him here said
that poverty is is a real problem in
Russia and the so called social protests
are up this year 56 percent over the
last year and people protest you know
the higher the rising utility costs
healthcare transportation housing
layoffs and I thought we would never
hear it from you know since the
post-revolutionary impoverished in 1990s
when the oil was 18 dollars a barrel
wage areas I said so called
social protest because both the regime
and the opposition seem to distinguish
rather sharply between what's going on
in in those protests and what they call
political protests where they are they
could be called political they're
strictly localized or at least that
seems to me I mean people protest
against a particular mayor a particular
governor a particular police force a
particular municipality but we have not
seen the repeat of the March 26 National
anti-corruption demonstration in I
believe 84 Russian cities now the I
wonder though in an economy where where
70 percent of the GDP is is either owned
or controlled by the government or
subsidized by the government in the
public sector there is always a tinge of
of politics in in every social protest
is that is that right well absolutely
there's always a fine line between so
in political protests and it's not
always clear where you droid I mean for
example a couple of years ago we had
those protests by long-haul truck
drivers around the country against this
new wrote Irish system that was
introduced in the one hand you can say
that well it's a social protest because
they're just protesting against you know
those new tires so they have to pay but
of course we know that that entire
system was introduced for the personal
gain of the rothenburg brothers who are
you know one of the closest oligarchs
politically and financially to to Putin
and his regime so I mean it's it's
debatable whether that was social or
political but I think what's what's
interesting about it we've always had
this notion for years in Russia maybe
for decades and and and you written a
lot about a to that you know at some
point it's those economic and social
protests that could become the drivers
of political change but I think actually
if you look at the last 18 years now
already over of the Putin regime the
biggest and the biggest political the
biggest protest the biggest street
protests that happened under the Putin
regime happened actually when the
economy was doing very well in December
2011 in January 2012 it had in fact
nothing to do with social economic
grievances in fact the people who came
out on ballot net and Sakharov having
you back end in December 2011 six years
ago now they didn't come for money or
for wages or for any social and economic
demands they came for the dignity they
came because they felt insulted at such
a blatant stealing of their votes you
know we are not cattle was one of the
most popular slogans on board now on
December the 10th 2011 and in fact a lot
of the people who came out to protest
we're representatives of the relatively
affluent urban middle classes and again
it was not about the social or the
economic issues it was about dignity it
was about people wanting to be citizens
in their own country as opposed to
voiceless subjects who could be told you
know that I'll be President he'll be
Prime Minister for the next 12 years
goodbye you know that was that was a
driving issue and of course those
protests that you just referred to that
we saw all across the country in the
last few months in March and then again
in June and then again in the last few
weeks with the so-called presidential
election campaign beginning and going on
the way of course the the March protest
as you pointed out exactly took place in
more than 80 towns and cities across
Russia in June it was already almost 200
it was a much bigger way from June the
12th Russian National Day symbolically
the day when the Russian parliament back
in 1990 doctored the declaration of
sovereignty from from the Soviet central
government and I think the most striking
feature of those protests I mean
ostensibly they were about corruption
and against corruption the pervasive
government corruption the immediate
trigger was that investigation done by
Nirvana's anti-corruption foundation
into the secret financial empire of
current prime minister dmitry medvedev
you know his yours his villas his
vineyards and tuscany and all the other
stuff but it was of course about much
more than that it was not just against
the corruption itself it was also
against the reasons the underlying
reasons that allow for this corruption
the lack of transparency the lack of
accountability the lack of the rule of
law and at the end of the day the fact
that one person has now been in power in
our country for 18 years let's just
pause and think about it Putin is our if
you count by the number of days Putin's
not even power longer than Leonid
Brezhnev the symbol of Soviet
totalitarian stagnation you know the
generation that the generation of our
parents grew up knowing nobody but
Brezhnev will never have in turn of the
generation of our parents it's back for
Oxford ok we now have an entire
generation in Russia who grew up not
knowing anything except the Putin regime
when I go around the country to
different regions as part of my work or
the open Russia movement and speech with
these young activists in different
places you know someone who's 18 20 22 I
have to remind myself that I'm speaking
to someone who does not know anything
except Putin you know I'm old enough to
remember what real elections are like in
Russia I'm old enough to remember the
government and the president harshly
criticized the national TV the people
who are now coming out to protest all
across the country
for them and something out you know out
of fantasy books they don't they don't
know this but they're instinctively
understand increasingly that it's not
okay in a European country in a 21st
century to have one man staying in power
for 18 years without regard for such
niceties as free elections and term
limits
and they're increasingly understand that
the fact that the government is
unchangeable and that it's not possible
to change it that elections are not real
that there are no checks and balances
there are no real institutions that all
that is the cause of the pervasive
corruption or the abuses of basic
principles of rule of law and human
rights and there is this growing
awareness of the link between the social
economic problems that exist and the
political situation that have caused
them and I think also and this is what I
what I just saw from from you know again
going all across Russia in the last
three years and speaking to these people
to these activists in different regions
we are seeing increasingly with many of
these young people their sense of
dignity and their self-awareness of
citizens of their country gradually
becoming stronger than the sense of fear
of political repression I think that is
a very important turning point it's not
gonna happen overnight it's not you know
it's not going to be a momentous event
but it's going to be it's a gradual
process but it's already happening and I
think we saw this very clearly with the
protest waves in March and in June many
of the people who came out to protest
and March of course this was the first
time ever so they came out to take part
in a political protest and many of them
as you know more than a thousand people
on a single day were arrested many of
them were jailed given 10 5 10 15 days
of administrative jail terms for Corin
quote mass disturbances this is what
this is Kremlin speak for taking part in
peaceful demonstrations and when when
they were coming out from those you know
from those jails after those
administrative terms you know they'll be
approached about journalists obeying you
know just friends and supporters and and
asked well presumably now you're not
going to go to protest again after they
said no no we're definitely coming out
again after this and in June there were
more people and more places more cities
and towns participated in the protest
then in March I think this is a very
hopeful trend for Russia but a very
worrying one for the Putin regime
well I get to watch Russian TV too circa
need to listen to the Duma deputies and
and to see some of the most popular talk
shows you would think that that Russia
is at state of war and and lady Amir
Putin is a wartime president just the
other week
he held a marathon for day non-stop
session with the top Russian military
commanders and as part of finalizing yet
another state armament program this one
is over three hundred billion dollars
continuation from the first program
inaugurated 2008 in much higher rubles
at that time it was seven hundred
billion but but by now it's probably the
same bottom line is Russia is committed
this one is to run to 2027 in the past
less than twenty years spent to spend
over you know two thirds of a trillion
dollars on armament at the signing of of
the program according to the Russian
media Putin directed all major
enterprises irrespective of ownership to
be prepared to expand defense related
production as he put it in the time of
need I can't recall anything like this
from before Pierce troika what what is
going on here
now he also said that every type of
production Russia must be prepared to
switch to my young ladies military Rao's
all these jokes and social media about
what's the right caliber of the pasta
that will need to be produced but you're
right we have I mean if not had it for a
long time but we have heard that before
and if you look at Russian state TV
enough so-called talk shows you know
that the hour of hate again to use the
old Soviet era if you watch or well in
term actually yeah but we use that a lot
of course so if you watch those which
which I advise you by the way not to do
if you value a nervous system but
sometimes have to just just to know what
they're thinking what they're doing you
would you would hear this constant well
war mongering is probably the best way
to describe it and and the propaganda
and just the
the intensification of hate and and of
you know to turning the US and to
radioactive ash and and talk about the
West now as enemies and of course this
constant search for traders and national
traders and fifth columnist and foreign
agents inside of Russia and this has
been going on for years now at an
increasing pace because well frankly
that's the only thing this regime has to
stand on they have to they have to kind
of ratchet out this rhetoric because
they have not much to you know to point
to in terms of their economic success
because there because there is none
other are very few you know they like to
pretend this of course as you know this
catchphrase that Putin's propaganda
often uses to describe you know what his
regime has supposedly done is that they
raised Russia from its knees that's the
phrase has been used for years but you
know if you actually look at what they
have done in terms of okay let's let's
accept their terms and let's look at
they've done and what they've done in
terms of foreign policy and geopolitics
you know under president Boris Yeltsin
who is now a demonized figure in in
Putin's state TV Russia became a member
of the g8 for example the most respected
club of world powers under mr. Putin
were expelled from the g8
I mean what's more were is not rising
from the knees because of the Putin
regime the behavior we now have very
harsh very biting general economic
sanctions
introduced against our country by the
leading economic powers of the world for
me that's not really something in line
with Russian national interests so they
have nothing to stand on in terms of
real achievements so they have to build
up this wall of pretense and propaganda
that everybody you know we are besieged
fortress everybody's against us and of
course the the enemies themselves
changed from year to year one year it's
Estonia the other is Georgia now of
course it has been that place has been
firmly taken by the United States for
many years now because that's the only
thing they have to go on I mean we can
discuss of what's actually real in this
and I know some people are seriously
raising the prospect or does it mean
they'll be you know war at some point or
something like that but I think this is
most of just a propaganda image that
they need
present something in the public sphere
because they have nothing real to
present at her show all right we'll come
back to Putin as a as a wartime
president Oh a footnote is that one of
the products probably a more conspicuous
product of that state Arman program is
what in the NATO designation a beret a
class nuclear submarine outfitted with
20 intercontinental ballistic missile
tubes launching tubes each capable of
carrying six independently targeted
nuclear warheads and the name of that
submarines Prince Vladimir we have one
standing by the Kremlin now did you know
as well on the bird you know oh there's
a new monument put up last year just on
the side of the various kk2 Prince
Vladimir well a fascinating issue is
also I think I believe the 8th monument
to Alexander the third which is but uh
probably in modern times the most
reactionary a Russian leader we if we
have time we'll touch on this a little
bit about the state of opposition senior
subtract presumably wanted to run from
Parnas the party of burying him so if I
believe your party at some point as well
but but Parnas demurred
specifically Mikhail Kasyanov citing the
lack of agreement with your elinsky and
Navarre and so-and-so sub shark is now
running from a fairly obscure party
civic initiative assuming of course she
collects one hundred thousand signatures
her program strikes me as quite liberal
especially you know concerning Crimea
Ukraine relationship with the West but
what is going on here could you could
you tell us it's a little bit complex
for me well I think what's going on is
the same that has been happening in the
last few elections election cycles
national election cycles in Russia so as
you recall beginning from at least 2008
genuine opponents of mr. Putin have been
blocked from participating elections
have been blocked on umbrella in 2008
this was Mikhail Kasyanov for for Prime
Minister and Vladimir Bukovsky the
famous Soviet era dissident in 2012 at
the height of the protests it was
grigory yavlinsky who was blocked from
the ballot and there according to
serious analysis from the time he could
have got quite a lot of votes because
that was the height of the protest
movement and he's not really a
polarizing figure I mean a lot of people
could have supported him just just
because that's that's the way of
protesting against the regime they
removed him and instead of him back in
2012 as you remember well the Kremlin
put up the billionaire me held Prokhorov
to imitate an opposition presence on the
ballot and in fact Prokhorov actually
missed the deadline for submitting his
nomination papers to the Central
Electoral Commission so the Central
Electoral Commission waited until 3
o'clock in the morning for proper office
representatives to come in I think
that's an unprecedented event in Russian
electoral practice and it's it's clear
why so when you say that you know when
you say diplomatically that provided
Ksenia Sobchak collects the required
signatures I don't think that's any kind
of a problem there were two genuine
opposition leaders who were planning to
challenge Vladimir Putin in a 2018
presidential election one was Boris
Nemtsov and he will not be challenging
Putin because in February of 2012 he was
killed on a bridge in front of the
Kremlin and the second is Alexei Navalny
who unless something astonishing happens
which I don't think it will will not be
on the ballot in March because he was
deliberately disenfranchised by the
Russian authorities through a
politically motivated cooked up court
conviction which was by the way
overturned earlier this year by the
European Court of Human Rights but was
then repeated word for word coma for
coma in a repeat conviction which was
exactly the same as the one overturned
by the ECHR earlier this year so in in
the absence of genuine opponents of the
ballot
I think the Kremlin still cares about
the international legitimacy at least
the veneer of inton
legitimacy of this so-called electoral
process and we can talk about more on
this later because I think that's a very
important point international aspect of
this so I think what they're doing was
senior surf check is trying to create
that veneer of international legitimacy
that look we have we have we have an
opponent of the ballot of course she's
someone who's been well I think we can
say a family friend Vladimir Putin for
years she's the daughter of his former
boss performers in Petersburg mayor
Anatoly Sobchak who brought Putin into
politics who who brought him basically
where he is today and and she said
himself several times that she's very
grateful to mr. Putin personally for
what she considers saving her father's
life but back in 1997 while there was a
prosecution being prepared against him
and Putin took him out outside of Russia
to Paris in late 90s if you recall so I
think let's not talk about Ksenia
Sobchak as a as a serious opposition
contender thing this is all a part of
the Kremlin's effort to build up a
facade of a legitimate electoral process
whereas in fact as everybody knows well
we have not had a real competitive
democratic election in Russia for years
and this is not me who's saying this if
you look at every single report by
observers from the OSCE and the Council
of Europe in every national election in
Russia after the year 2000 they have
concluded that every one of them failed
to meet basic democratic standards it
was not free not fair and not
competitive
I do not think we can expect any
surprises in this regard on March the
18th and since we are on this point I do
want to talk about the International
aspect of this since we are meeting in
Washington the capital of our fellow
member state in the OSC the Organization
for Security and Cooperation in Europe
one of the main mandates of which is
actually election observation so every
time after the year 2000 observers from
the OSCE and also from the Council of
Europe assess that elections in Russia
do not meet the basic standards of
democracy that they're not free not fair
not democratic
yet every single time the leaders of
those same countries
of the OSC and the council view of the
leaders of Western democracies
recognized the results of those
so-called elections and called Putin to
congratulate now I'm puzzled as to how
those two things make sense at the same
time I'll never forget March the 5th of
2012 this was the day after Putin's
so-called election victory in 2012 we
had a big opposition rally on Pushkin
Square Square right in downtown Moscow a
couple of miles down from the Kremlin
and I remember there were tens of
thousands of people and was standing on
a stage all the main opposition leaders
in Russia were on that stage Boris
Nemtsov was there grigory yavlinsky was
Alexei Navalny was there Garry Kasparov
was there and there were tens of
thousands of people just to see your
faces and flags people Russian citizens
who came to express their anger that
their votes being being stolen in such a
blatant fashion and as we were standing
there so there's there's an eight hour
difference as you know between Moscow
and Washington I was about 7 p.m. in
Moscow so it must have been about 11
a.m. here and as we were standing there
we got news that the US administration
issued a statement of congratulations
not only to Putin which would have been
half the problem but to the people of
Russia for having held this presidential
elections and have to tell you this felt
like an insult and it wasn't just the US
that same day on the 5th of March David
Cameron the then Prime Minister of the
United Kingdom became the first Western
leader to call Putin and congratulate
him on an election victory and he did so
on the same day and alongside Hugo
Chavez and Bashar al-assad so we really
hope and I know I speak on behalf of
many colleagues when I say this we
really hope first of all though there'll
be vigorous international observation of
the so-called presidential election in
Russia on the 18th of March we hope that
observers from our fellow OSC member
states including the US make their
conclusions and hold the cronin
authorities to account with regard to
the international obligations that the
Russian Federation's undertaken in
election standards under such documents
as the OSC charter of Paris the OSC
Copenhagen
and protocol number one to the European
Convention of Human Rights and if these
conclusions and these reports are
similar to the ones we have seen every
time for the last 17 years I really hope
that the leaders of Western democracies
do not legitimize the results of the
so-called election and do not
congratulate mr. Putin on yet another
successful theft because in effect that
is what they're congratulating him on
and I think frankly this is the least we
can expect of the leaders of countries
that pride themselves on having
democratic governance and the rule of
law though I did maybe I should combine
there was a part of my question
essentially hinting at the perennial
inability of the of the Russian
opposition to unite when I said that you
know per NOS cited inability to the
inability to create a united front with
Navalny and any of Linsky why don't we
combine that also with the so called
systemic opposition the the I promise to
return to Alexei Kudrin I'm returning to
him he chaired the Congress just the
other week of the Civic Forum which is
his presumably you know loyal but
nevertheless opposition and and there
was even a debate between him and and
the mayor of Moscow still gates have
been so what is going on there well I
remember as you pointed out right at the
beginning I'm also historian is one of
the one of the hats and I remember
reading so much about the debates that
were going on in in the West among
Western criminologist about the
so-called doves and hawks in the
Politburo that there was supposedly
different camps and these have you know
these were really good ones and in you
know wink wink I really you know they're
they're really fighting for something
good and in within the system and then
in 1991 92 when Yeltsin open the
archives especially during the process
of the judicial process against the
Communist Party of the Soviet
at the Constitutional Court in 1992 when
many of the former Central Committee
archives were open all these documents
came out and we saw that in fact all of
those so-called doves and so-called
hawks in the Politburo voted exactly the
same way in all the major issues war in
Afghanistan and you know the Exile of
Sakharov Tagore key everything they were
all in complete agreement so it was all
just a big hoax so I wouldn't to be
honest pay as much attention to those
different you know color variations
within the system within the regime
because although you know some of them
are supposedly more reactionary someone
supposed to do more about liberal some
of them are certainly much more you know
Pleasant on a personal level I mean
Alexei Kudrin is a very nice man I mean
I see him from time to time in Moscow
it's always pleasant and interesting to
have conversations with him if you
compare him you know somebody like
Rogozin who's supposedly on the other
spectrum of this regime this there's no
comparison but that's the person level
there's Deputy Prime Minister yes
absolutely
the guy who said once that he'd gladly
exchange his current position for
sitting in a trenches and a Donets
People's Republic and of course people
have then remarked that he probably
wouldn't fit in any trenches in there
thank you so what he looks like but
again I think we can discuss the
differences on a personal level but I
think fundamentally all of these people
they're all part of this regime and the
old work for its preservation and its
you know maybe will in a little bit
changed form but still first
preservation and you mentioned that term
of course systemic and on systemic
opposition I think that is a key term
you know I would I would just call it
you know a non-systemic opposition is
the real opposition right the so called
systemic opposition is not an always
compare it to how the East German
parliament while by the way of course
mr. Putin spent many years in his
Germany I remember when he was coming to
power 18 years ago people who wanted to
see something good and everything they
said hawa he spent time in Germany he
must must have been influenced late well
he wasn't although it was the wrong
Germany of course that's the point
an East German parliament as who
remember also had a multi-party system
on the face of it it was not a one-party
state like the Soviet Union they
actually had the Christian Democrat
Union they had a Liberal Democrat Party
there the peasants party I think
something else but of course that was
all the big Hulk's also they all voted
together with mr. hora
all the time and and so it is for the
for the current so-called marching party
party official system in the Duma and
what exists in our country all of these
so-called Duma opposition leaders are
completely unanimous when it comes to
all the major points for the regime in
fact we have I was speaking at a
conference recently there was a
representatives of the opposition from
Papua New Guinea and he said he came out
to speak and and he said well the
situation our country's so bad we only
have one real opposition member in
Parliament and when the break began I
came up to him and I said you know were
you really lucky cuz that's one more
than we have we have zero there's not a
single genuine opposition good coffee
spelled and or yeah well basically
spelled yeah until until until last year
that was one to mean she could cough and
of course again Boris Nemtsov was
planning to run for the Russian
parliament last year in 2016 in fact as
you know absolutely in fact he was again
to go back to your term non-systemic
opposition of course the the way we used
those terms done on systemic opposition
is supposed to signify genuine real
opposition as opposed to the systemic
one which is the people who pretend to
be opposition who sit on legislative
bodies and those two things are
incompatible either your real opposition
or you sit in a legislative body Boris
Nemtsov became the first and so far the
only leader of the non-systemic
opposition to actually win an election
as she did in Yaroslavl four years ago
in 2013 despite all the odds despite all
the obstacles he won election to the
regional legislature there and he was
planning to run for the Russian
parliament in 2016 from Yaroslavl from
the single-member district now remember
when the late 2014 beginning 2015 his
campaign was already kind of beginning
to be underway he had a campaign staff
formed newspaper registered and they
were taking the first initial surveys
polling in the in the district and I
remember that this will only they only
have time to do one but that first
initial poll showed his starting
position at 25% which people who know
much more about you know election
campaign technologies and I do told me
it's an amazingly high number for the
start from before anything was even done
in terms of real campaigning so there
was
there was a good chance that he was
going to win a seat in the current
Russian parliament and then of course he
was prepared to challenge Putin in 2018
well it's such a rare treat to have you
but to snatch you between between your
various trips I'm sure a lot of people
would want to ask you a question so let
me ask you one last one so returning to
Putin as the wartime president you know
wartime presidents generally are not
supposed to be changed unless the war
ends preferably in victory and there has
been kind of a swirl of rumors in in the
Russian media about proposed changes in
the Constitution among other things you
know nullifying the the ban on on more
than two consecutive terms or creating a
parliamentary republic so Putin could
become the Prime Minister executive
Prime Minister from from whatever party
he would like so what what do you think
of all of this and beyond that and
purple anticipating the question what
will happen in in 2024 Putin is going to
be only 72 I mean look at Mugabe his
he's finally out of power but that's
that's a very young age so so what do
you think I've recently read a paper
where the assumption was well you know
Putin will spend his term thinking of a
successor because you know because he
can can't run anymore
will he be thinking of a successor I'm
not sure I think I would there are two
very important questions in there and
I'll start with the one kind of that the
one connected to the regime the last
point I think it was Howard Wilson
British prime minister once said a week
is a long time in politics so I think
it's to talk about what's gonna happen
in Russia in seven years that's that's
in the realm of fantasy what I would say
is that it was if
first of all I do think Putin wants to
stay in power forever mm-hmm I do think
that I think he made a decision to
pretty early on around 2003 which was in
many ways a turning point in his regime
that was the year just in one year three
major things happened he shut down the
last independent nationwide television
channel CBS he j-rok offski which was an
unmistakable message to the Russians
Russia's business community it was best
to stay out of politics and basically it
was an attack when any kind of
independent activity by the big business
and it was of course the year of the
first rigged national election in
December 2003 the election which saw
genuine Democratic opposition ejected
from a state duma both especially a
blocker both pro-democracy liberal
parties so I think it was back then that
he made the decision that he wants to
stay in power forever and everything
that he's done since has I think
corroborated that but on the other hand
if it was up to it if it was only up to
the dictators and their wishes to stay
in power forever then every dictator
would stay in power forever everywhere
in history of the world and of course as
we know that's not what happens and
Russian history has a funny way of
having major you know shifting massive
political change start like this and
this is a good year to discuss it it's
the Jubilee year in 19 in 2017 I am old
enough to remember August 1991 and you
know so many ways a formative experience
for me and for people in my generation
and you know if someone said at the
beginning of August of 1991 but by the
end of August 1991 there would not be a
Soviet regime it not many people would
have believed it but that is what
happened and much more recently again if
in September 2011 at the time of the
casting that's the term right there are
also one Putin matter and Putin Medvedev
announced a job swap if somebody said to
me or some many of my colleagues back
then I thought three months from now
there'll be a hundred thousand people
standing across the road from the
Kremlin demanding Putin's resignation
you know would have thought that person
is living in cloud cuckoo-land
that is what happened so Russian history
has this funny funny way of showing
dictators and dictatorial regimes and
authoritarian regimes that it's not
always up to them what's going to happen
and this is where I want to come to the
first part of your question you
mentioned constitutional changes I think
you mentioned it in terms of what the
regime might might want to do changing
the system you know for them to stay in
power forever but I want to turn this
around a little bit and talk about the
actual importance of having a
constitutional change in Russia this is
what we want to do and one of the major
policy positions and positions of
principle for our movement for the open
Russia movement is to change Russia from
a presidential to a parliamentary
republic the genuine parliamentary
probably a lot of fake one was the one
you referred to if you know a way for
Putin to stay in power forever but
actually a real parliamentary Republic
because you know when people ask us so
ok you you don't want Putin to be in
power but who do you want to replace him
with and we say we don't replace him
with the who or replacing with a what
it's not a question of changing the
person at the top it's a question of
changing the system it hasn't worked out
well in Russian history I think we can
say this certainly from by now when one
person had all the tools and all the
instruments of power in his or her hands
mostly his so I think the question is is
Andrew p.m. Koski who's in the audience
here today once wrote we don't want to
change a bad czar for a good czar won't
have no czar at all in Russia and that
is a very important point there is no
such thing as a good czar and so what we
want to see in Russia after Vladimir
Putin is a much more balanced system
much more parliament if not a pure
parliamentary system that at least a
much more balanced mixed presidential
parliamentary system something they have
in France for example we think we should
get away from that paradigm when
everything depends on one person so the
goal of our movement as well as I know
many other political parties and
movements in the Russian opposition is
to move to a different system
after Vladimir Putin in one way or
another voluntarily or not very
voluntarily leaves power because again
since Russian history shows us that
political change big political change
happens quickly and usually begins
unexpectedly we need to be preparing for
it ahead of time because one of the
things that happen both in 1991 and in a
way in 2011 is that many of the
Democrats were not ready for what was
going to come we can discuss the many
mistakes that were committed by the
democratic government in the early 90s
and we can discuss the many mistakes
committed by the opposition leadership
at the height of the protests in
2011-2012 I think many of those mistakes
were fundamentally caused by the fact
that things happen so quickly and
unexpectedly we never know when next big
political change happens in Russia it
may be well before 2024 so I think our
task as a responsible opposition
movement is to be preparing for that
change now and this is what we are
trying to do because one things start
happening it's too late to sit down and
try to figure out what to do now well
excellent so we have about 15 minutes
for questions so please ask them you
know in a in a bring the Edit form
please there's a microphone there by the
way congratulations to the beautiful new
facilities here for AEI dr. to your
point about replacing who and what after
the Coordinating Committee period and
Balat and I am it seemed that the
Kremlin had identified adults off as
probably the most dangerous figure of
the Opposition after all he was the one
they actually jailed and it seemed that
the other ones they slow rolled now
putting his personal qualities aside one
could say demographically maybe that's
because of who his base was if you think
that the goal is to replace what instead
of who what Navalny and Volkov and the
others are doing now and the nation
dignity that you identified among the
what is it that you think the opposition
that you'd like to see is poised outside
of Moscow and Peter to take advantage of
this change as opposed to an adult soft
or an adult soft like figure speaking to
that base again outside of Moscow and
Peter okay thank you for the question
well first of all let's say that the
most dangerous opposition figure for the
Kremlin was Boris Nemtsov that is
something much worse to him than I did
all those off what also thankful he's
out of prison now a couple of months he
was in prison if he count the home
arrest for more than four years and and
just as a just as a footnote we have
more than a hundred political prisoners
in Russia today still some of the
prominent ones release adults off was
released Darya peluda was released the
remaining balata net prisoners were
released I think all of them now
literally in the last few months but
let's not forget there are more than a
hundred political prisoners in Russia a
117 by the latest count by the Memorial
Human Rights Center itself of course not
designated as a foreign agent the human
rights organizations once founded by
Andrei Sakharov and they used very
conservative and even observe stricter
criteria to designate somebody as a
political prisoner and even by that
creates a criteria based on resolution
nineteen hundred of the Parliamentary
Assembly of the Council of Europe and
even according to those criteria we have
117 political prisoners in Russia just
supported in context in 1975 when
Sakharov wrote his Nobel Prize lecture
he listed 126 prisoners of conscience
and I was of course USSR which was twice
as big as Russia so we're back to the
same kind of fingers I think the most
important point I think that you that
you refer to is the need to go outside
Moscow and st. Petersburg those have
been well I think for centuries we could
say the traditional hotbeds of political
activity everything in Russia always
happened in Moscow and some Petersburg
and were the big protests that we saw in
these last few months
which was saw this paradigm at least
beginning to be broken especially with
the June wave when almost 200,000 cities
literally from Kaliningrad to
Vladivostok to pardon his protests and
you know some of these places have not
seen any political protest well at least
since 21 maybe since 1917 some of them
and and now as we see Nevada for example
go around the country in his unofficial
presidential campaign which he's
conducting he's gathering you know
thousands of people on the squares in
places where nobody thought any
political activity could exist came out
of a Jeff's getting people you'd not the
places you automatically think of when
you think about opposition activity in
Russia so I agree completely with your
point I think it's very important to go
beyond Moscow and Peter's working to go
outside to go to the country to
different parts of the country we try to
do this as open Russia as well we now
have 28 original branches as of as of
this week the last one was open three
days ago and at all and we feel it's
important also to break this paradigm of
everything happening just in Moscow and
Petersburg and you know in the last
three years since we've relaunched open
Russia I've seen more of Russia than in
my whole previous life I mean because we
could because we try to try to spread
our work and do a lot of work in the
regions who that's off of course is
somebody who represents a very very much
left-wing political tradition and of
course since he was jailed he's also
just like navona he's not allowed to
contesting elections now there's this
they made up this law a few years ago
which by the way there's nothing in the
Russian Constitution about any such
limitations and taking part in elections
the only limitations the Russian
Constitution mentions is that if you're
actually in prison according to a
current sentence then you cannot take
part in elections or if you are insane
or if you are below the age of 35 if we
talk about presidential elections no
other limitations but the but Putin and
Matt print of the State Duma have
rubber-stamped all these additional
restrictions in the last few years now
if you have dual citizenship you cannot
running elections even if you have
residency permit abroad you cannot run
in elections if you have even a
suspended court sentence which isn't the
vine you have you cannot run even if you
were released from prison like oh that's
off like horochowski for example you
cannot run in any kind of election so
they put up all these additional
barriers we think
of course needless to say that you know
every Russian citizen who's eligible
according to the Constitution including
food also should have the right to run
in elections and we also think that it's
important that the opposition and this
has go back to the water not the who
that the Russian opposition has many
strong political figures within it of
different political persuasions people I
couldn't solve all the less people like
Navalny people like me and good Kafka
was already mentioned the full number of
the State Duma people like left Slavs
Berg a very prominent figure in the
Russian opposition well the leaders of
the yeah blocker party he was the person
who three years ago now provided the
first documented definitive proof of the
presence of regular Russian troops in
Ukraine which was of course something
the Kremlin lied about and denied and
when he did this
this wasn't scoff he's a member of the
regional Parliament in scoff and he was
obscure paratrooper division that was
sent into Ukraine members of it were
killed there and then they were brought
back in body bags and buried like dogs
in unmarked graves with numbers instead
of names because the Russian defence
ministry did not want to admit that they
were there and Schlossberg found them he
took pictures of them he published it in
his newspaper he was beaten up he was in
a coma in hospital he was stripped of
his parliamentary seat and then last
year he was elected back to the regional
Parliament by the people of scoff he is
a member of parliament now again people
like him people like you've gained your
voice man who is the current mayor of
Ekaterinburg the fourth largest city in
Russia what are the most prominent
figures in the opposition today he
wanted to run for regional governor from
yeah blocker earlier this year he was
again blocked from the ballot not
allowed to run so we think there should
be many strong political figures in the
Russian opposition and although I
disagree with probably most of what
Sergey odintsov stands for politically I
certainly think that he should have an
absolute right to run in elections and I
think when we have a freely elected
parliament in Russia one day he'll most
likely be a member of it
Andras under Solon Atlantic Council
thank you very much for an excellent
analysis and as always I have a standard
question what can we do and I'm thinking
particular two issues one is this as
sanctioned law now the section or 241 of
pointing out people closer to the
Kremlin do you think that this can be
effective and BR the question is Putin
got obviously furious over the release
of the Panama papers in April 2016 and
all that it exposed about him do you
think it would be effective if the US
really really reveals the riches of the
Putin crowd but obviously exist in this
country
Thank You Anderson it's always great to
see you and thank you for the questions
when we were discussing this issue Boris
Nemtsov came up with his formula back a
few years ago when when you know when
people ask him what should the West do
with regard to what's happening in
Russia he would always say don't punish
the country go after the scoundrels that
I'm gonna throw back [ __ ] Jaffna cosmic
and this is of course what section 241
does and you had an excellent panel up
on Capitol Hill a couple of weeks ago
along with Andre and other colleagues
and I think this is in this whole law
that was passed last summer this is
probably the most important provision
section 241 is the provision that tasks
the Department of Treasury the State
Department in coordination with a
Director of National Intelligence to
publish a report by the deadline of
February 2nd of next year 2018 detailing
the people and naming them by names the
people who have political proximity to
Putin and his regime the oligarchs the
politically powerful officials to detail
their involvement in corruption to
detail the non Russian business
associations to the foreign business
associations they have and I know for a
fact that in the last few weeks many of
these people have sent emissaries to
this to this city to try to approach you
know lobbyists and people on the hill to
see if it'll be possible for them not to
be named in this in this report and I
think yet again the Kremlin shows what
is the most sensitive point for them and
the most sensitive point for them is
when you go after that personal
financial interest and this is what we
always say again as Boris said don't
punish the country go after the
scoundrels we do not think it is right
to punish an entire country for the
actions of a small unelected clique
sitting in the Kremlin and this is why
the Magnitsky act was such was so
brilliant in the principle that it
introduced that you should actually
assign responsibility for corruption and
for human rights abuse where it is due
to the people who perpetrate it and so I
would say this would be the most
important thing that Western countries
can do I mean if you listen to Kremlin
propaganda they will tell you that you
know we members of the Russian
opposition go to the west and we ask for
money and for political support or we
ask you to effect a regime change in
Russia whatever other nonsense they come
up with of course none of that is true
we're not asking for support for us the
only thing we ask our friends and
counterparts in Western democracies is
that you stop in effect supporting the
Putin regime first of all by treating
him as a respectable and worthy partner
on the international stage which
amazingly after everything that's
happened some Western leaders still are
trying to do but also and perhaps more
importantly stop supporting the Putin
regime by allowing his cronies to use
Western countries as havens for their
looted wealth you know as havens to
store the money they've stolen from the
Russian people because again those
people want to steal in Russia but spend
in the West and by allowing them in the
dirty money into the Western countries
and the Western financial systems
Western democracies have an effect in
enabling I have no other word enabling
this corruption and this human rights
abuse and so it's very heartening to see
the four countries already the US Canada
Estonia Lithuania have passed full-blown
Magnitsky acts that introduced this
principle that if you engage in
corruption human rights abuse you will
no longer be entitled to a visa and to
using the financial and banking system
of Western countries we hope more
countries do that and this section 241
he's of course very very important and
although it does not entail sanctions
per se just is just a report of just
publication I think given their nervous
reaction it's a safe bet to say that
those types of things are the most
effective ones and I would also mention
another thing that I think is important
and I know some people dismiss this a
small and symbolic what I'm going to say
now and although it is symbolic it's
certainly not small Russia is a country
of symbols as you know I always remind
people of this one after the victory in
over the coup leaders in August 1991
Muscovites went to the labiancas Square
to take down the statue of George insky
because that was a symbol one of the
first things the Putin did when he came
to power was to return the Soviet era
Stalinist national anthem again a symbol
of what was of what was to come
it was a very powerful message for those
who are willing to listen so what I'm
going to say now that's a symbol but
it's a very important one tomorrow
on December the 6th and this is actually
the reason I'm in Washington this week
there will be a hearing at the
Washington DC City Council on the bill
that would designate the Block in front
of the Russian embassy here in
Washington on Wisconsin Avenue Northwest
as Boris Nemtsov Plaza in memory and in
honor of the late Russian opposition
leader Boris Nemtsov would try to move
this initiative initially through
Congress where it was blocked by senator
bob Corker chairman of the Foreign
Relations Committee as was reported last
week in The Washington Post and as
Alexei Benedict tell the editor-in-chief
of a chemistry radio station said
publicly this week he told the story of
how in July during the g20 summit there
was a meeting that was the first meeting
between Donald Trump and Hardman Putin
but before it there was a meeting
between Sergey Lavrov the Russian
Foreign Minister and Rex Tillerson the
US Secretary of State and apparently
this is according to what venediktov
said three days ago literally apparently
that meeting in July they recited there
went through different issues that need
to be addressed and resolved for the
bilateral relationship to get back on
track they talked about Crimea and
sanctions in Ukraine and Syria and
apparently according to venediktov
Foreign Minister Sergey Lavrov
specifically asked Tillerson
not to rename that block in front of the
Russian
see after boris nemtsov so again anybody
who tells you that symbolic things are
not important I think that's the best
answer so from what we understand mr.
corker because of this request and
administration blocked it but thankfully
there is also jurisdiction of the DC
City Council over DC not just Congress
so the DC City Council has taken up this
initiative and they're moving ahead with
it tomorrow is going to be the first on
the only public hearing on the bill I
will be testifying in favor of this of
this of this measure as well
Jean M Silva Boris nemtsov's daughter
who is flying in today she'll be
testifying tomorrow and the reason this
is so important for us what I'm going to
say at that hearing tomorrow it seems
we're not allowed to honor the memory of
a Russian statesman in Russia the
astonishing thing is that the Kremlin
and the Putin regime are still fighting
Boris Nemtsov today even after he's dead
they have rejected every initiative
every public petition for any kind of
commemoration in Moscow forget about a
street name not even a small sign
nothing and you're the reason they gave
for this they said there's a lack of
consensus now we have streets in Moscow
named after ago Chavez the late
Venezuelan dictator we have a street in
Moscow in the south of Moscow sure in
butovo named after akhmad Kadyrov the
former chechen strongman this is the guy
who once declared a jihad against Russia
and once called earnest followers to
quote kill as many Russians as possible
end of quote there was no problem with
consensus for naming a street in Moscow
after that guy but the former Deputy
Prime Minister of the Russian Federation
there seems to be a big problem with it
and there were signs that were put out
by the residents of the apartment
buildings where Boris lived in Moscow in
Yaroslavl then we're taking down within
days more than that almost every night
the Moscow municipal authorities and the
Moscow police come in to the bridge to
the unofficial memorial on a spot where
he was killed because more than two and
a half years old people's things people
still bring flowers and light candles
and put pictures kind of unofficial
makeshift memorial and they take those
flowers away and they pillage it and
they destroy it and you should see the
videos or videos of this on YouTube and
Facebook film by volunteers you have
grown men in police uniforms stealing
flowers in the middle of the night so
they
still fighting him they're still
fighting his memory and so what we're
gonna say tomorrow that council hearing
is that apparently we're not allowed to
honor a Russian statesman in Russia so
we're very grateful to citizens and to
elected representatives of three
countries who are stepping in to do what
we cannot do and there was of course a
precedent for this also set in this town
and also connected with Russia in 1984
the US Congress designated a small
stretch of 16th Street northwest in
front of the old Soviet embassy to sell
the Russian ambassador's residence in
honor of Andrei Sakharov who was down in
internal exile in Gorky this was 1984
and of course as you can imagine the
Politburo and the Soviet foreign
ministry were furious when this happened
but I was remind people only seven years
after that and this goes back to the
question you said you know when one can
we expect change in Russia only seven
years after 1984 in 1991 the Russian
ambassador installed proudly installed a
bust of Andrei Sakharov inside the
embassy itself and he was still by the
way standing there the last time was I
was declared non grata in the Russian
embassy in 2012 the last time all's been
those five years ago but I was still
standing there and this is how things
change in Russia so I have absolutely no
doubt that there will come a day when
the Russian state is proud to have its
embassy in Washington standing on Boris
Nemtsov Plaza and I know that they will
all be very grateful for our friends in
western democracies including here in
the US who made this statement and made
this point it's very symbolic but it's
certainly not small well I'm afraid we
don't have time for any more questions
but Volodya was brilliant as always
thank you so much
you